ei ei
Oi boa tarde
Tá bom eu não vou contar minha história
para vocês hoje
hoje eu vou falar sobre história eu
trabalho com história então vou falar
sobre ela
Oi eu queria saber com vocês se vocês
conhecem esse cara
eu acho que ninguém né
um bom nome dele é Tom seu Watson e ele
foi o fundador da IBM
Ah mas eu queria saber com você e se
vocês conhecem esse caro
Eu acho que já é mais comum né
é bom quando vocês se relacionam com a
marca da Apple quando vocês se
relacionam com produto o que que vem à
mente o que que é a marca da Apple acho
que a gente lembra sempre do Steve Jobs
E por que que acontece isso a gente
lembra de quem ele foi o que que ele fez
EA gente relaciona isso com a marca
bom então ele falou que ele quer deixar
marca dele no universo eu acho que ele
conseguiu entanto os outros conseguiram
tantas pessoas que deixar sua história
marcada eu gosto de falar o exemplo do
Ayrton Senna Nelson Mandela Albert
Einstein E por aí vai são melhores
Tá bom então se você quer deixar a sua
marca no universo
conte sua história
hoje nós vamos falar de história eu
queria falar como é que acontece uma
ligação covalente para nós formar uma
molécula de água eu acho que a gente
conheceu assim né quando a gente tava na
escola quando a gente era criança e aí
tem uma molécula de oxigênio tem uma um
átomo de oxigênio dois altos de
hidrogênio e a gente recebe essa
informação de forma racional ela não
atingir o nosso coração será que eu não
poderia ser uma informação e motiva a
gente atingiu o nosso coração depois do
nosso cérebro
o que raiva gênica é melhor friend
É sim ela tem cabelo rapidinho
I
am the last One Standing On
o
gato próprio dinheiro não deixa eu já
vou achar aqui fazendo
uma criança assistindo isso ela vai ter
uma interação com personagem
Ah então é ela tá recebendo aquela
história aquilo que atinge o coração
dela ela não tá recebendo de forma
racional e o que que é isso o que que a
história deve ter acima de tudo empatia
e o que que é empatia empatia a gente
sentir o que o outro sente e Uma
História a gente sentindo que o outro
sente o que o personagem sente o que a
pessoa do nosso lado está sentindo a
gente vai fazer da experiência dele
sendo a nossa experiência isso é empatia
se a gente tem alguma pessoa no nosso
lado que perdeu o pai a gente através de
empatia vai sentir naquele momento o que
que é perdeu o pai
E aí
me
ajude a
E aí
o
Ítalo e Cauã Rey II
e a história provoca empatia com os
personagens
EA partir disso O que que ela mais faz
quando a gente está ouvindo uma história
o que que acontece a gente conhece a
pessoa de verdade que quer dizer você já
deve ter ouvido a pergunta de quem você
é o quê que a gente costuma responder
quando a gente responde essa pergunta
a gente costuma falar eu sou Fulano eu
sou médico a gente tô falando nossa
profissão lá eu sou engenheiro O que que
a gente fala nossa profissão que que tem
a ver
e eu acho que a nossa profissão foi a
grande escolha que a gente fez ao longo
da nossa vida e a gente escolheu se
aquilo Esse é um momento importante e a
gente é a nossa escolha Nós somos o que
escolhemos ser
e o que são escolhas na história são
dilemas é uma questão de nomenclatura
bom então a gente se a gente mostra que
a gente é a partir das nossas escolhas
é importante falar que é muito mais
difícil tomar uma escolha escolher um
caminho a seguir se a gente tivesse
sobre pressão
bom então eu vou dar um exemplo simples
de como que a gente conhece mais um
personagem mais uma pessoa numa história
que ela passou pressão é só imaginar o
seguinte tem um executivo imagina o
Executivo viu indo trabalhar tá indo de
ônibus ele tá lá no meio e no meio do
caminho sofreu um acidente Aquele ônibus
acabou começou a pegar fogo então quê
que ele vai fazer ou vai ser escolha
dele Será que ele vai fugir ele vai sair
correndo ele vai tentar salvar alguém
talvez a partir da Escolha desse
personagem nesse momento a gente vai
escolher quem ele é
é isso a gente coloca mais pressão em
cima dele a gente vai conhecer mais
ainda quem ele é
então vamos imaginar que ele ficou ele
mostrou ser um personagem corajoso uma
pessoa corajosa
Oi e aí ele pensava naquele momento que
tem ele vai salvar alguém e tem duas
crianças do lado dele e ele só tem tempo
para salvar uma e de repente uma criança
ela é branca e a outra é negra e qual
será a escolha dele será que esse
personagem vai mostrar de alguma forma
que ele tenho uma um preconceito de cor
e às vezes ele nem sabe disso às vezes é
inconsciente então quanto mais pressão
mais a gente com essas pessoas mas a
gente conhece os personagens
e eu tenho um exemplo também que é muito
bom falar que ia colocar o Ayrton Senna
que ele virou um herói nacional e é um
cara que corria de carro então ele fazia
a minha avó acordar cedo para ver ele
correr que que é isso esse é o poder do
storytelling em ele e o legal que a
história dele foi contada
muita muitas partes da história dele ao
vivo na TV então isso formou Quem é Quem
foi aquela pessoa e aí tem vários
exemplos ele por exemplo a gente
reconhecer alguém aí foi a pessoa não
sei se vocês lembram que gosta de
Fórmula 1 e 91 ele nunca ganhou no
Brasil e ele tava correndo e ele tava
ganhando e deu problema no carro dele
Então faltava sete voltas para terminar
a corrida ele ficou só com sexta marcha
para quem conhece de automobilismo e é
um carro naquele momento só com a sexta
marcha é muito difícil e é muito duro
então deu espaço muscular nele bom então
naquele momento com aquela pressão que o
piloto tinha ele tinha uma escolha e ele
pensou várias vezes eu vou desistir não
vou aguentar eu não tô aguentando mais
não sei nem mexer o braço e tá pesado e
ele continuou ele ele escolheu naquele
momento que ele ia conseguir que ele ia
ganhar a corrida e ele ganhou a corrida
e com a gente conhecer um pouco mais
naquele momento quem foi aquele piloto
Olá
seguindo então eu vou falar quais são
alguns principais elementos que uma
história deve ter
o e são esses fatos que eu vou no meio
aqui agora
e O legal é que a gente a palavra
história né como que a gente ouviu tanto
hoje no tédio e tantos outros eventos
comum como pede mesmo a gente usa essa
palavra todo momento né E esses
elementos estão inseridas nessas
histórias contadas e depois a gente não
organiza tem um objetivo uma motivação e
um conflito Esses são os elementos
principais de uma história todo história
deve ter eu vou dar um exemplo
o Star Wars Luke Skywalker Qual é o era
o protagonista Claro do Episódio 4 para
o objetivo dele naquele momento é
resgatar a princesa Léia e a motivação
dele era trazer paz para universo e qual
é o conflito que ele tinha naquele
momento é o império o exército Imperial
Darth Vader Breaking Bad A gente tem um
outro Watson protagonista e o que que
ele queria agora objetivo dele dinheiro
e a motivação dele cuidar da família
Oi e eu confio tudo ele era a própria
polícia e os traficantes
Oi e o Ayrton Senna de novo tem uma
história real que eu gosto de falar é
objetivo dele era ser campeão várias
vezes ela de botar o nome dele na
história do Esporte e o a motivação que
ele tinha era superação Essa é melhor do
que ele mesmo em todo momento e o
conflito que ele tinha era tantos
adversários dele ou uma própria política
da Fórmula 1 naquele momento ele que ele
passou
e o importante desses quatro elementos e
que a gente deve trabalhar na nossa
história
em geral o que tem de mais importante é
curiosidade a gente tem que trabalhar
com curiosidade para o nosso
interlocutor para o nosso espectador a
todo momento então a combinação desses
elementos a gente tem que gerar
perguntas do espectador do tipo E aí só
que você vai fazer isso você vai
conseguir chegar lá você vai conseguir
atingir esse objetivo é isso pessoal a
gente vai conseguir de repente no
primeiro momento o personagem não
consegue mas se depois só que ele
conseguiu E você tem que gerando essas
perguntas no interruptor no interlocutor
no seu espectador a todo momento ele tem
que acompanhar sua história do início ao
fim
e o mais legal disso tudo
O que é conflito a história tem que ter
conflito e o conflito ele tem que ser a
história tem que ser difícil se não for
difícil não tem graça Então a gente tem
que pensar dessa forma na história
pessoal
difícil gera nossa história ser melhor
Oi e um conflito que tem que ser tão
grande quanto a nossa força a força do
protagonista de seguir em frente ou até
maior e o que que o conflito gera o
conflito gera brecha o que que é brecha
brechas são histórias histórias on
brechas isso resume tudo
e vocês lembra o que que você estava
fazendo o dia quinze de agosto de 2005
eu acho que não só se for de aniversário
de alguém por acaso lembrar mas vocês
lembram O que que você estava fazendo o
dia onze de setembro D 2001
e esse dia foi uma brecha
vocês não lembro no dia um dia
específico que vocês foram ou voltaram
de carro do trabalho Você se lembra do
dia que furou o pneu vocês lembram do 7
a 1
e eu quando eu tinha 10 anos eu e o
pessoal do bairro a gente queria fazer
uma casa na árvore e a gente tava uma
motivado para fazer que ia ser o clube
dos meninos e tal eu tinha 10 anos mais
ou menos e a gente conversou construir e
a gente percebeu o negócio ali que tava
faltando na casa na árvore
as meninas não podiam subir porque ela
que cuida dos meninos
e a gente fica a gente fez aqui que uma
criança de 10 anos faz para impedir isso
a gente conseguiu uma armadilha
E aí já tinha uma pouco de madeira né
que é para subir na árvore e última hora
falso Então a menina ia segurar e a cair
para trás
se eu cair na armadilha a
e eu tava em cima da água e Fui descer
eu pensei que tava sem o topo Eu apoio a
minha perna e raspou ele raspou no prego
aí quando eu desci olhei para minha
perna eu vi o meu urso
a Vitória na
essa foi minha brecha eu lembro disso
porque não sei porque a gente começou
aqui o urso todo dia
eu lembro desse dia então o que que é
brecha a gente pera aí do lado a ao
ponto all.be alguma coisa não deixar
história isso
Olá pessoal a gente pensar no seguinte
vamos colocar um exemplo aqui é um cara
quer ligar para uma menina e falar que
gosta dela aqui olha ela pagar o
telefone dela para ligar para o amigo e
vai pedir o telefone dela o amigo do
telefone ele liga fala isso Acabou
porque história de né ruim
nós vamos colocar brecha de repente ele
vai ligar para esse cara tenta ligar
para essa menina ligou para o amigo e
pede o telefone e o amigo falar ela vai
embora do país Ela tá no aeroporto agora
Opa história foi melhor agora tem brecha
e o interessante falar aqui agora é que
vão acontecer presta os atrás de brechas
isso que a gente tem que trabalhar que
que eu quero dizer
e a gente quando vai realizar qualquer
som durante o dia é óbvio que a gente
vai gastar o mínimo de energia possível
o cara ele vai ligar para mim ele não
vai alugar um helicóptero foi para casa
dela é ótimo ó
é isso não vai dar certo então ele vai
ter que gastar mais energia para tentar
atingir o seu objetivo e também não vez
não vai dar certo e ele vai gastar mais
energia para atingir esse objetivo até
gastar o máximo de energia possível para
chegar lá nesse exemplo de repente ele
pegou um táxi e ligação mais energia
para isso e talvez no meio do caminho
furou o pneu do táxi outra flecha então
de repente a pegou carona talvez a
carona Foi um sequestro
a outra brecha Então tá enrolado oposto
objetivo dele até de repente nessa
situação ele de repente assumir o poder
novamente e foi para o aeroporto e
conseguiu encontrar a menina uma menina
já foi embora do país e isso é um
roteiro de comédia romântica dos da
Maria dos fios né então ponto mais
energia você vai gastando para você
atingir o seu objetivo isso quer dizer
que brecha está relacionado ao risco
brecha é diretamente proporcional à
risco
o que que você quer dizer então talvez
então quanto maior o risco maior chance
de acontecer em brechas
E aí
bom então a nossa história ela pode
ficar mais e memorável se a gente assumi
maior risco Porque vão acontecer mais
brechas
E você tá disposto a correr o risco
necessário para deixar sua história
memorável essa gente pensar numa várias
histórias de personalidade de novo igual
Steve Jobs que usei no começo Steve Jobs
não determinado momento da vida dele ele
assumiu alguns caminhos ele fez algumas
escolhas e ele foi mandado embora da
empresa
Então foi uma grande brecha na vida dele
naquele momento ele ele recuperou isso e
depois ele deu a volta por cima Nelson
Mandela e um determinado momento da vida
dele ele fez algumas escolhas Ele foi
preso então foi uma grande brecha na
vida dele Oi e o Airton a gente pode
colocar até como exemplo o dia da morte
dele que era um risco muito alto para
quem conhece a fórmula 1 naquele momento
Tava tendo uma discussão sobre segurança
no dia anterior tinha morrido um piloto
já mas ele não ia deixar de correr ele
ele Dizem que ele até pensou mas ele não
ia deixar ele assumir esse risco ele
morreu e foi grande brecha e história
dele ficou memorável também por causa
disso
Ah tá e como é que a gente bota tudo
isso em prática e conta a nossa história
isso é estrutura e o que que é sutura é
muito simples é só vocês pensarem Vocês
estão numa dinâmica de grupo e vocês tem
dois minutos para falar quem vocês são
vocês são um bar e vai conhecer alguém e
aí naquele momento você vai falar vai
conversar com a pessoa e ali você vai
mostrar quem você é o que que você
escolhe de falar quais são os pontos que
aconteceram na sua vida que você vai
falar naquele momento que vai mostrar
quem você é e o melhor Além disso Qual é
a ordem das coisas que você vai contar
e quando você for falar isso você vai
mostrar quem você é e dependendo uma
dinâmica de grupo por exemplo ou até no
bar mas diante do grupo você manter uma
pessoa que de repente fala e a gente
lembra mais de quem é aquela pessoa né a
gente leva mais uma pessoa Talvez do
jeito dela contar ele a gente quer ser
essa pessoa porque a gente quer ser
lembrado a gente quer falar que a gente
é aí que os outros lembro da gente a
gente quer tentar no bar e conversar com
alguém e quer que o outro lembrou da
gente a gente quer conhecer alguém aqui
no intervalo a gente quer que a outra
pessoa lembre da gente
então pronto vai a sua história mostra
quem você é e você tem que saber contra
ela eu e mais do que isso ela vai
mostrar quem você é e você vai ser
reconhecido por isso quem você é e o que
você fez você vai ser lembrado por isso
e pode ser para o mundo pode ser para
sua família pode ser seu amigo pode ser
um cliente com um parceiro de trabalho
eles vão conhecer melhor Quem vocês são
através da história pessoal que vocês
contarem e como vocês contarem esse é o
mais importante então se você quer
deixar sua marca no universo
com a sua história obrigado